hey Conan O'Brien here welcome to Conan
O'Brien needs a friend I think my voice
becomes more and more professional with
every outing I'm taking a lot of pills
to voice pills uh well professional
pills pure testosterone what to try and
get me into a lower register oh that
smooth jazz register Matt good to see
you good to see you uh Sona nice to see
you as well same how about ditto does
your does your generation ever say ditto
or is it always same no because my son
says same he goes same does he say
Samesies no he doesn't do that he's like
a normal kid
do you think he's holding a giant
lollipop investors dressed as a sailor
in short
pantsies
no I don't say ditto no no I don't do
you you know I've never heard you say
ditto I used to say ditto Daddio back in
the 50s but uh that was a long time ago
you know I don't want to blither and
blather today because I think this is
kind of an important podcast this
episode this podcast in general or the
whole podcast I just think it's an
important part of American History you
couldn't even finish the sentence you
couldn't do it I tried no I I'm excited
about this episode uh because today uh
is a conversation with Billy eilish and
her brother Phineas and uh I I love
their work I really do I think they're
very talented and I was very excited
because I don't think they do a lot of
stuff that they were going to come into
the studio and talk to us and it was uh
it was a fun it was really fun
conversation it was so fun and they're
really cool and you know they came with
like their parents who were also really
cool yes but it made me wanna like I I
really wanted them to think I was cool I
I could tell that you were a little
self-conscious I was I think I'm saved
from that because I know first of all
I'm old enough to be their father if not
their grandfather oh but so that so that
takes away some of the pressure there's
no effort for me to try and be cool with
Billy eilish and Phineas I don't feel
that pressure at all is that true I
don't I do I don't think so well I
wouldn't know because I was relegated
back in the nosebleed seats there in the
shadows so you guys could have and your
mic was turned down in our ears
Conan's request really oh that's my
normal seat yeah you're describing where
I usually sit right it rise up yeah I
don't I don't think it's right either
well here's what happened because
there's two main chairs and two
microphones uh usually if there's one
guest
um the guest sits there and then you sit
in your seat but because it was Billy
eilish and Phineas there was no choice
but to place you in a Ralph Supermarket
several blocks away I'm seeing another
mic stand right here I know we've got
extra mics I'm just wondering we
couldn't have you creeping up in between
Billy Idol yeah absolutely and if not
sandwiched in the same chair at least
okay no creepo and I'll take either of
them absolutely not you wouldn't have
had roommates she got really comfortable
at one part and then as she was getting
comfortable I was too this is what I I
was going to say about Billy eilish's
star power so she's sitting in the chair
you're in now Matt and she as you both
saw almost immediately she got so
comfortable she started to and no other
guest has done this she started to slide
down the chair and she just kept sliding
down the chair until I was basically
just looking at Billy eilish's head yeah
it's true resting on the chair her body
completely disappeared and Phineas got
very comfortable and then at one point
out of the corner of my eye look over
and I see Sona and you were mirroring
Billy eilish you were way down as if you
were on a transcontinental flight In
First Class yeah you reclined all the
way you ordered some warm cashews and a
Pinot Noir and yeah you put on an eye
mask you were so chill and I was sitting
on a milk bucket in the shadows
I think that if I did what she did I
would be cool like her I think that's
what I was doing the reason it's she's
Billy eilish is that she's not thinking
about any of it she just is well also
she's 21 and I'm 40.
that may help yeah I also I think this
episode sets the record for the most
times I've been called dude in one
conversation yeah yeah she's they're
very Californian I don't know about you
but I wanted to be like hey man I'm from
California too bro hey dude hey dude I
was going to be he would like you
so did I get it that's why you were on
the milk bucket what I understand that
yeah
I think you should have gone a bit
farther yeah maybe the other room would
have been better hello dudes I live in
Pasadena and I am most jugular as well
why my dudes what's spanking
what's spanking my chili Willies hey
guys cool wanna come to the Rose Bowl
swap meet with me and we could find some
Bakelite gmods hey I'm going up to
fuckman's LEAP to have some cordials
later wanna come what wow you lost me
completely I don't know what you're
talking about everybody got lost with
that well it'll come out
[Laughter]
I don't know it just came out wait so
you don't even that's not even a real
thing I don't know what it is who
improvises fuckman's leap that's insane
that is not coming out that is a pure
moment of insanity out of my mouth
before but I don't know what it is
man hey dudes we were on a riff about
you being Square in front of Billy
eilish and then your attempts to be a
quote Square guy is to say we're all
going up to fuckman's League which for
the record is the coolest sounding place
I've ever heard in my life and boom that
shows that I've got it oh my God I want
to die on fuckman's lead I don't know
Brian committed suicide today he jumped
off fuckman's leaf
his wife could not be reached for
comment because she was too busy
laughing this is the problem we're doing
a whole day of segment and intro
recordings and there's no celebrity in
here today I mean no offense uh
and it just feels too like groovy you
know we're too jazzy right now I'm too
comfortable I think it's great if it
brought us fuckman's leap I say more of
this Jazzy and groovy anyway you're so
cool you're so with it